[Music]
one of the things that I think was a
theme in everyone's introduction an area
focus is this whole concept of
interoperability there's a confluence of
events that is happening and it presents
us with a really unique opportunity for
changing from disease day to really
prediction and Andrea I'd love to hear a
little bit about the data strategy that
you're pulling together and how that's
going to help further the state of you
know this this future of health concept
so NIH as we've been we've been going
down this experiential journey I call it
over the last few years in our data
science base and we just issued this
past year our first ever data science
strategic plan trans-nih trans disease
trans domain and I would encourage you
to go on our website and take a look at
that but we we identified five key
things we really are trying to look to
how we can best leverage the tremendous
advances in technology with our
incredible scientific expertise and
research expertise and harness that in
more powerful ways and they'll require
some cultural change historically we
fund about three hundred thousand
researchers a year at about twenty five
hundred academic and medical centers in
our country in some cases globally and
so researchers at a time develop their
collect their data analyze their data
test their hypothesis store that data we
have all of this data resident anywhere
you can imagine right someone's desktop
someone's server campus Medical Center
data center etc and we can't find it we
can't access it easily we certainly
can't interoperate across various data
domains and datasets and we can't
sustain it we can't reuse it so we're
starting over again almost every time
and so our strategic plan really focuses
on five key target areas first and
foremost is to work more in partnership
with industry
and non-traditional partners who have
the expertise in advances an
infrastructure and compute we don't need
to buy that a researcher at a time we
need to use that researchers time to do
the scientific advancements not to
figure out how to set up my server and
my data structure and what tool I need
to use right but the the other is
looking at the algorithms and the tools
we fund a great deal of that looking at
how we can educate and train and orient
our next generation scientific
researchers with the tools and
capabilities they need to take advantage
of these new artificial intelligence
machine learning these vast datasets our
big data set programs now are in the
tens and 20s and 30 petabytes size
ranges these are huge data sets we're
moving all of these to the commercial
cloud we can't sustain them locally
anymore we want to bring the researcher
to the data with a relatively available
tools with their own tools they can do
compute by themselves they can do it
with someone else they can leave what's
there for the next researcher right and
we believe that's the that's the model
of the future and so we are trying a lot
of different approaches and techniques
including policies and other things for
requiring data management plans and
having people think about how they're
going to share and sustain that data but
we believe that's how we'll accelerate
discovery in ways we've never been able
to do in the past that's great Doug I
know that one of the things that you
have been thinking about is working with
clients to really look at archetypes
what are the archetypes
in the future of health and I'd love to
hear your thoughts on what are some of
the archetypes that you think are really
you're seeing a lot more of your clients
talk about and specifically maybe some
of the challenges yeah
we've we've coined about 10 different
archetypes and they range from as we
talked about here sort of the data
convener the data analyzer at the date
of manipulators and the interpreter has
set a one end of the spectrum all the
way through to how do we finance this in
an equitable
way.when if you can predict the risk of
a populations disease state or wellness
state you know where what is the role of
health insurance
both catastrophic and pooled insurance
and so that kind of individual financier
and is a part of the future you know the
way we buy health insurance could be
dramatically different because of the
predictability of a population and the
predictability of yourself I think one
of the other themes that has come out
and our point of view around the future
of health and and it kind of relates to
the concept of getting the data to the
researcher in your environment we also
talked about that we as individuals will
own our own data and own access to our
own data meaning we will be in the
driver's seat not only of owning that
data that's either owned now by a health
plan a you know a research organization
a health system of Life Sciences
Corporation but how do we create that
interoperability so that we can own it
and we can also grant access to that
data so another kind of archetype would
be is you know the idea that the
individual will own the data and
therefore be able to grant not only
access to it but they can use their own
data to make some decisions especially
if you can layer on sort of a cognitive
AI layer to get them access to the
latest and greatest clinical trials as
an example you know don't wait for the
hospitals to suggest it you know be
doing that you know kind of shopping for
yourself or for lack of a better way to
put it I think the only other final
element in that that I'll talk about
that we talk about a lot is the retail
ization of healthcare in general I just
got off the phone with CEO of a big
Health System a few minutes ago and his
point of view is you know what's the
role of the emergency room in the view
in the future where you know healthcare
is going retail and that the consumer is
expecting the same level of retail
experience interaction that they do at
you know they're very favorite you know
restaurant and retail situation and
other service providers so I think the
whole element of you know the the retail
ization and whether that becomes like a
health hub kind of concept that becomes
our virtual concept meaning you get care
wherever you want to have care including
in your home I think are some of the
major shifts that were we're predicting
that's great one of the things that
we've been thinking about are some of
the trends and I Shema I know when we've
talked you've highlighted some of the
themes around interoperability and the
connectivity to future health I'd love
to hear from you what are the things
that you're excited about what are you
the things that you're seeing
specifically from your role at Google
cloud so what we hear as much of what we
are building comes from what we hear
from our partners from the industry and
how do we enable Andrea and Cardinal
health in in a lot of industry
stakeholders from the mission
perspective Google is a mission oriented
company you know us as a consumer
company and if you're hearing our
quino's we are making our best attempt
and we are really engaging with
enterprises much more deeply for past 20
years we have built technology from the
consumer world that we're now making it
available to enterprises a truly
democratization of infrastructure
democratization of artificial
intelligence and then democratization of
Records which is the interoperability so
our mission statement from Google is a
very timeless statement which is to make
information securely accessible and
useful in healthcare our mission is to
enable enterprises to really organize
healthcare information may ticket
accessible and useful and if I have to
translate that when I say organize that
means security compliance you need a
platform to get the data that Andrew
talked about when we say accessible
that's what the interoperability comes
in right if the data is locked up in a
in a system and I'll give you an example
we're all consumers of healthcare
and this is an example I use often how
many health apps there's an app for
everything maybe there's a diaper a gap
is a they how many apps do you think
exists in the App Store's any guesses
take a guess like fifty thousand a
hundred thousand it's not billion here
the last I checked with like 250
thousand plus hey there's an app for
everything and now I'll ask a second
question how many of those apps do you
think connect to your patient record
like two percent rate that's the
opportunity when we as consumers are
given these tools and we talk about
patient empowerment but if the glass
layer of the app is not able to connect
to my patient record that's what
accessibility and interoperability comes
in and then the third part is to make
the information useful that's where we
are applying a iron machine learning and
we strongly believe to apply a machine
learning in healthcare where the data is
so diverse and the standards like fire
hl7 we are teaching our cloud to speak
language of health care how many 14 are
familiar with fire in title seven I'm oh
this is the healthcare proud the grace
of that that's what yeah so we want to
speak we want we are teaching the cloud
from the cloud perspective our enduring
team our product team are focused on
building product solutions to talk hl7
to talk fire because we believe not only
the data normalization would be
important but this is a gateway to apply
AI machine learning because you don't
want to build models which are working
on just one set of data that's where the
standardization in semantic
interoperability with fire becomes
important and as I said before we all as
a consumer will benefit from it and how
many folks have here I've heard of sent
the 21st century cares act well so
according to Seema we're mothers were
mounted hymns by 2020 if patient want
access to their data and the provider
systems
responsibility to give the data in the
form of an API it's coming down this is
the started with President Obama so it's
that's where we will now as a person
that you were talking about I have
access to our own data we are API and
the tools that we're building is to
enable that and teaching those languages
I think that's great and John I know you
have talked about how cardinal health is
using AI and ml to help your business
would you share with the audience how
you're thinking about it now and in the
future and any learnings that you've
seen as you've implemented it yeah I'd
say werden just at the beginning of it
so I think a lot of companies are in the
same boat of how do we leverage this and
and it's not it's not as easy to consume
as we would hope right so we have data
scientists on staff they're expensive
we need more what we're hopeful is with
Google auto ml and developments like
that where me and I'm definitely not a
data scientist could use it and say hey
give me some insights out of this data
pool I've got a whole set of data and I
could almost ask questions like in a
natural language query or something like
that I think it's coming and I think
it'll be faster than we think but that's
that's a little bit where we're
struggling right now we're getting some
benefit but I think it's nothing
compared to what we'll see in five years
any any immediate learnings that you've
seen as you've started to implement I'm
not familiar with that okay one of the
things that I think is interesting with
what each of you have said is really
around ecosystems so there are many
traditional folks that you're working
with and you'll continue but one of the
themes that I think has come out in each
of your you know sort of future talks
about where the health markets going is
working with people that are slightly
different so Andrew yeah I'd love to
hear I know you all are NIH are doing
some really interesting things around
sickle cell and around rare diseases and
like to hear a little bit more about how
these ecosystems are playing out yeah so
you know we we have we've tended to you
know studied by
zees or by data domain or data type and
I'll share with you so 2003 we did the
human genome program that was three
billion dollars and took decades
multiple more than ten years to be able
to solve that problem in 2003 or 2003
2010 to seven years later it was ten
million dollars in months now it's less
than a thousand dollars and minutes
right to do this so in that same window
of time we saw the rise of the
electronic health record and went from
zero adoption to almost full adoption
but we haven't figured out really how to
take advantage of that and incredible
changes in image imaging data so MRI and
scanning data right so the what we're
seeing is incredible advances in in
discovery in diseases that we just could
never deal with so we have one of our
programs we have a precision medicine
initiative we believe this is a key way
that we're going to accelerate discovery
we're looking for a million cohorts and
its participants we literally changed
the language you're not a patient you're
a participant and the research journey
you contribute your genome data your
electronic health record your
environmental data so we know your
Fitbit data so we know about you in your
world in your history how you live and
in about your health and along with a
million other cohorts of very diverse
people then why does that matter
think what you can do with preliminary
clinical trial ideas if you have access
to that kind of rich data across diverse
over multiple years that can accelerate
the billion dollars and ten years it
takes to get a get a healthy you know a
drug a successful drug to market there's
like a 95 percent failure rate right so
if you can do virtual clinical trials in
these rich data sets think how how much
we can learn from
Alzheimer's every 66 seconds someone is
diagnosed in our country with
Alzheimer's I mean just the time we've
been up here think how many people that
is right this is a crippling economic
and devastating disease for our country
and we're looking at only in how we can
how we can solve the problem treat the
disease but also how we can use
computational capabilities to predict
well in advance symptoms and signs of
people based on their keyboarding skills
based on their movement in action in
home in sits you right to help get you
to the drugs and treatments sooner we
think sickle cell is on the horizon
we're gonna have one of the first HIV
free generations I believe in my
lifetime I will see that and and so
these diseases are are we can we can
deal with them right we can we may not
be able to resolve them all but we can
treat them we can get treatments to the
market faster and it's and it's this
data this merger and intersection of the
ability to access data to have more
participant in persons centric health
and and in your health journey and the
computational capabilities that is just
it is game-changing you know today a
computer is as much a scientific
instrument as a microscope was fifteen
years ago
and so it's an exciting future I think I
would add to that I think we are talking
about artificial intelligence but she
learning I maybe have a little more view
from the pragmatic approach in health
care even the connectivity itself as a
big issue right AI is a next step but I
submit to you if you don't have a solid
data strategy billing in AI strategy it
was not gonna take you far so I'm good
with examples one more example I'll
share with you so let's say today we all
talk about digital campaign reaching out
to our consumer really helping them and
poverty em to take care of their
so today let's see if you are running a
query maybe a population health where
you want to make an outreach to all the
female who are aged from 45 to 50 who
have a brother gene for Braco one and
barakatu had the mammogram three years
ago haven't checked into their position
in past 18 months hey there's no
predictability here you're looking
backwards and you want to find out and
make an outreach to that population
because they need to be come and see and
get them i'ma ground and how many folks
here in this room think we can connect
all the things today and done such a
query right there's no way I hear one
person okay you sir are ahead because
why because you're imaging our living in
some pack systems some in data center
your health records are a natural seven
you're paying information what time you
will is in your membership system how do
you connect that and that's where the
cross modality analytics requires
platform like cloud where you're
bringing in this data you're normalizing
it and you're able to run those queries
to make that that outreach to your
patient to your consumers to really help
them with their journey to be healthy
and once you have a solid data strategy
the data analytics you can really build
an AI layer what but I worry now when I
do talk to a lot of customers or we want
AI it's not a pixie dust
it's yes we want the I but you really
need a solid data and they're just hard
work it's mundane it's complicated and
that and that's where we want to help in
taking in I call I so glorified plumbers
to get those pipes to get this data
normalize it this is what Google is good
at and make it easy so that then you can
build your next level of artificial
intelligence tools and do the good
things and innovate and and build those
really empowering capabilities I think
that's great and Doug I'd love to hear a
little bit from you or
when we think about the archetypes what
archetype do you see Deloitte playing
now and in the future I would say it's
in my opinion from a Deloitte
perspective we have a unique situation
where we get the opportunity to work
with many many different parts of the
ecosystem that don't normally play tit
well together you know if you think
about retailers and healthcare it's not
natural for them to play together but
we're seeing that the retail ization of
healthcare is happening and we're in a
unique circle you know way because we
have the opportunity to serve all the
healthcare organizations and the
government plus you know big retailers
as well so driving that ecosystem play
that integration obviously the the many
of those retailers are making plays
themselves you know at and CBS coming
together I think we're gonna see that
kind of burgeoning you know retail
ization of healthcare and those big
retailers getting into healthcare and I
buy it by opinion bring it on I think we
need to innovate I also think we're have
this unique opportunity to work with all
of the really important technology
giants and you know again you know we're
here talking about Google but in my
opinion bring it on the ability and the
innovation that the tech giant's can
bring I think is a really really
important element to to innovate
healthcare way faster than we've done
before the third element that I think is
kind of a forgotten a little bit element
of our healthcare system and that is the
association's the Canadian cancer or the
American Cancer Association
you can tell I'm from Canada the the MS
Society and I think we're gonna see a
new lease on life in the trust factor
that those organizations have had in a
disease specific way and what role they
can play around data sharing providing
insights there's some great examples out
there where for different disease states
you know the the the Association is
getting together with you know Google
as an example and creating that trust
again the movement towards you owning
your data is happening we talked about
but the movement towards you sharing
your data into a pool to allow for
greater advancement and discovery is a
little bit slower on the uptake and I
think you know that the association's
play a really key role and you know
we're helping kind of put stitch those
those partnerships together that's great
interestingly as you're all talking
about the future one thing it's clear
things are going to be different and I'm
curious John as you start to think about
the team that you need to really move
forward how does it look does it look
any different
are there different skills that you're
going to need from the workforce to help
really support your organization yeah
that's gonna change dramatically first I
want the pixie dust
you guys should trademark that right now
just pixie dust
AI yeah definitely I think everybody and
we're seeing this just across all
industries everybody is becoming a
little bit of a computer scientist a
little bit of a data scientist it used
to be there was the Nerds and there was
everybody else right and the Nerds would
sit and they would stitch together the
computers and they'd write code and then
but now everybody just every every
profession you you have to learn at
least a little bit about computers and
data analytics and so I think you know
I'm we're dealing with this a cardinal
health is an IT as we shift to the cloud
everybody's like well should we or
should we learn that's like well I can't
tell you exactly what but here's some
here's some good ideas things that won't
ever go out of style and I think that's
that's gonna apply to even professions
lawyers doctors medical professionals
everybody's gonna have to be a little
more computer literate that's great
Andrea you are the CIO of one of the
coolest missions in the United States
and we're here with some of great tech
leaders what are some of the things that
you would like to see from people that
are interested in working at NIH and and
why come to NI
partnership first of all we're looking
for partners not providers not not
here's the answer to your problem if you
just buy this we really are in an
experiment experiential journey that's
what we do research is a long-term
horizon but we want to make it more
agile more facile more adaptable and and
more expedient right so we need people
who are committed to that mission who
want to advance discovery and accelerate
discovery and help for people all around
the world and so I like to say you know
there's a NIH has a big footprint right
so whatever you do it might seem small
but it has impacts on people's lives
truly around the world in ways that
you'll never ever fully realize there's
never a time that I don't talk to groups
like this that someone doesn't come up
and say you know my mother was at the
clinical center of the world's largest
Clinical Research Hospital in the world
and it was that research that saved her
life
or my son is in medical school and was
funded and supported by the National
Institutes of Health
right and trained under those dollars so
everyone has its health is personal
right it's it's you your health your
family's health your children's health
there's nothing more precious to us than
our health and well-being and so it is
such an honor to be at NIH and it is
such an exciting time to be there we are
looking traditionally we hired you know
they call them lab researchers bio bio
informatics people biologists chemistry
what we know about the biological system
and health is so small compared to what
we need to know right after all of these
years and all of this time and so now we
need data scientists we need engineers
we need technologists we need
communicator
we need that kind of team science to
really help integrate and merge some of
these ideas because we do that's where
the discovery is going to be it's not
going to be in the traditional you know
vertical they'll still be discoveries
there but the ones that will be
game-changing are going to come from
this cross fertilization and diversity
of experience background and
perspectives we believe that very
strongly
Puma may be a one question before we
open it up to the audience we've talked
a lot about data we talked about
interoperability like to hear your views
on security and and the things that are
sort of top of mine for you in that
regard that's a great question and
before I answer that having come from
the Kaiser world and having build those
systems the the I know legacy is a bad
word we are seeing gonna use it the
system that have been built in the
healthcare assume the patient to be in
the facility right if I got sick I went
and saw the doctor BTR be it my primary
care physician that paradigm has changed
on a set right now
you people are expecting care where they
heart but the systems are not designed
to be accessed from outside when you
talk about echo system we are talking
about telehealth we're talking about
Eva's it's all the system that have been
in place they serve the purpose when the
people were visiting physically in that
facility and now when we're moving to
care where you are paradigm that
security layer becomes very important
right people don't know how to open the
systems right how do you do single
sign-on what is it no it's right these
are basic skills and we want to me the
industry where they are and building a
lot of security based portfolio it's
it's super important to us Google Cloud
recep a compliant but we are all
building new and brand capabilities and
HIPAA Security is the paradigm there
like security audit ability who has
access to your system you're talking
about partners so that becomes one part
the second part I would say is
focusing on the innovation and letting
the infrastructure be I would say for
Google cloud but there's a that's where
we want to align our course trends and
provide value to the industry so if you
are passion while racking and stacking
in designing the chips of the
infrastructure join Google right so but
I would want you to really work on how
do you build those capabilities on this
world-class infrastructure because
that's where the democratization would
come from and right so don't solve to
solve problems is my my message to you
solve the problem that our patients need
like we need like consumers need and
this the problem that have been solved
by by the big tech or the infrastructure
we take security way seriously we have
hundreds of security engineers and
they're experts in their field that
better available to you now and that's
where the true democratization comes in
and the third thing I would say is crowd
is not just a left and shift strategy
and I do see that even today right it's
truly transformation it's a means to an
end the end is not if you've just taken
a server from your on premise and move
to the cloud that's not what this
transformation is about it's truly
looking into the business transformation
looking into like in the scary paradigm
getting that out there in cloud B that
means to to to the end and you define
the end your strategy that's where we
need to to get to I think that's great
and Andrea I know this is really
important to you anything to add on the
security front no I just think in the
research world one of the things that's
really important for us is that we we
protect the data not just for security
and privacy reasons but to honor the
consent agreement by which you consent
to give your very important data to be
used for research purposes and we build
those controls and to honor that consent
it may be that I only want it used for
if it's federal funded and not for a
profit entity or if it's in particular
areas of study and so that's a level of
complex
that we've been dealing with it
particularly as these datasets have
gotten so big and and one that we
continue to work on our studies and
surveys and and work has found that
people are very willing to contribute
their data for the bigger cause my help
the betterment of people around the
world but they they want the assurance
that my privacy what I'm consenting this
data for is is going to be protected and
that there won't be any issues with it
being used for purposes other than what
I give it and and that's a that's a
that's something we spend a lot of time
and effort of money trying to make sure
we honor that we are absolutely
committed to that because that that's
that's that's what is reasonable and
should be what people should expect and
I think as we move more towards this
participant managed you're managing your
health care your health profile that's
going to continue to be even more
important I would love to hear one word
that help it makes you kind of summarize
the future of health that describes what
you're thinking as the future comes
Andrea optimistic empowering I was gonna
say optimistic hopeful I'm gonna say
wellness wellness so thank you
incredible dialogue
[Applause]
[Music]